in that first full year on the road I
worked 50 out of 52 weeks on the road
what well I don't want to be on the road
for first steps and first words and so I
moved back home 7 months after I had
gone to L I appreciate you sharing that
I haven't heard anyone talk about that
side of them before I mean we can I mean
I don't want to give all my
secret did you ever have any moments
when you wanted to like quit doubting
the whole decision to quit a corporate
job to do
this High breath what's goody hot breath
the verse welcome back to hop breath the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros I am your host comedian Joel buyers
and our guest today has something most
Comics don't work life
balance his 25-year comedy career
started after quitting his corporate job
to where he would go out on the road for
up to two and a half months at a time
grinding it out sleeping in his car a
lot of the times yes he did do all the
comedy things that we strive to do as
comedians he did make the move to LA he
did get a Comedy Central special he did
get on Just for last Comedy Festival and
so many more things we see as success
but all of that taught him he would like
to see his family more so he created
some side hustles that became so
successful as businesses he is now able
to do comedy whenever he wants which
includes having dry bar specials with
over 50 million views between all of
them to now having his own businesses
and raising a family what a comedian
that spends with his family so we're
going to get into all that and much more
so ladies and gentlemen hot Brethren and
sister welcome to the hot breath ofe Mr
Josh sne everyone thank you Joe that was
very nice of you yeah that was very kind
of you to say those things it's very
true it's true I mean uh you they were
there were factual statements you know
um it's it's funny like it's you know uh
it doesn't seem like that long ago where
I was the com that was like couldn't
wait to be on the road like I had no
place to be I wanted to you know I
wanted to sleep in my car because that
meant that I was like so far away from
home to do standup that it didn't make
sense to drive back you know what I mean
so like with the with that comes a lot
of good memories like hearing you say
those things because you know there's
some some benchmarks in there you
mentioned that you know when you first
start doing Open Mic nights they're just
kind of like dreams like what if what if
you got your own Comedy Central special
what would it what would the background
look like you know I remember that's
what I used to do with the open micers
to sit around and go man if you ever got
a Comedy Central special what would what
would your backdrop look like that was
back when you could actually pick what
it uhuh was and I was like oh mine would
look like a like a empty school
classroom and I was in detention you
know writing sentences on the chalkboard
and then I got my special you know and
and one of the phone calls was like what
what do you want your have you given any
thought to you know what the set should
look like and I was like I know exactly
what I want it to look like I've been
thinking about this you know for years
and then walking into the theater in New
York to film it and then just like
seeing it like built out laid out on the
stage it's like I mean that's like dream
come true kind of stuff you know and it
makes all that stuff that you talked
about worth it you know
and then you just kind of get to a point
in your life as a as an adult at least I
did where it was just like I want this
to stay fun I want this to to be
enjoyable for me for as long as I feel
like doing it cuz when I first started I
met so many Headliners that they kind of
hated comedy they had like a an
animosity um toward it because it had
taken everything from them personally
right it kept them on the road to where
their relationships with their spouse or
their children or close friends had kind
of Fallen by the wayside because they
weren't around and I just uh it it was
like a double you know a double whammy
for them because they didn't they didn't
like doing it anymore and then they also
didn't have like a a real home life and
I wanted to sort of preserve both of
those things so that's why I had to try
to
find the side hustles you know to to
when I started them they didn't have to
be successful right then but the thought
was one
day if these can provide enough income
to make it so that I don't have to be on
the road all the time then that would be
the ideal scenario and then I'm you know
I'm very lucky that that worked out how
long in your career did you start
these so the t-shirt company I started
in ' 05 so that was 18 years ago um and
that was started with a buddy of mine so
that was 18 years you've been doing it
25 correct so s years in into your
career you're already thinking okay let
me get a little strategic here I got on
like a a fairly quick path I think in
terms of at least at that at that time
of how quickly I transitioned from just
kind of doing open mics and local shows
to going in fulltime so February of 98
that was the first time I ever went on
stage it was a month before my 21st
birthday and I just fell in love with it
right away you know and being 20 working
single no kids like it was so easy for
me to just be at the comedy
club every night you know just soaking
everything I could learn in like a
sponge um and Cincinnati didn't have a
real big scene we had one Club there
weren't like it's not like today where
there's like you know shows in people's
basement and stuff like it was like you
got on stage at the open mic night or
you didn't really get on stage and so um
you know I just I just tried to work as
often as I could locally um to learn to
get better and then start to try to
build relationships with some of the
headliners that were coming through town
and I was very blessed with um you know
Greg Warren is a friend of mine he's the
first person that I ever met in standup
he ran the open mic night when I started
and he was also a Proctor and Gamble
employee at that time which he talks a
lot about his new special selling peanut
butter yeah so it was like we had a lot
of parallels he was you know he's just a
little bit older than me but we were
both had corporate backgrounds and he
was just like so like if you're going to
meet one person as the first person in
standup like that's the guy you want to
you know to kind of be like a little bit
of a mentor I don't know if he'd call
himself that but he really was for me
and so um I I got as much work as the
the club would give me and go banana is
my home Club being the only Club in town
and being known as like a really good
club they were able to get like just
awesome Comics I mean they'd have
Chappelle and Hedberg and Geraldo and
you know like all the guys oh my God
watch them and I'd get my first pick I'd
get to work with them oh yeah so they
would say like you know
so a long story longer when Greg
transitioned from running the open night
to really starting to look at having a
full-time career in comedy I took over
the open mic night and at the time the
open mic nights were not very well
attended by audience members and so we
were trying to think of a way to get new
open micers because what we learned was
when somebody does stand up for the
first time they tell everyone they know
so if we could get more people to try it
we could get more people to come watch
it and so the only request that I had
for taking it over was that if that I
got to host all of those shows and that
I got my I got first choice each month
of which week to MC because there
weren't a ton of MC's either so uh so I
would cherry pick like all the guys and
you know that come through town and uh
and it was just so beneficial to me and
I think it helped me get better quicker
you know what I mean like having having
real amounts of time at a good club in
front of real audience is helped me
progress a little bit faster and so in
July of
01 Proctor and Gamble announced cutbacks
and um offered voluntary separation
packages to anybody that wanted one and
so I just thought that you know here's
my chance you know I was I was kind of
going back and forth on whether or not I
wanted to do comedy full-time and I felt
like I had made enough relationships
with some Headliners to get me in some
clubs outside of my you know Cincinnati
radius and so uh so I I took a voluntary
separation package and so I found myself
doing standup full-time like three and a
half years after I started oh my gosh so
by the time 05 came around I'd only been
doing it you know seven years but I'd
been on the road fulltime for four years
wow and that first full year on the road
2002 I worked 50 out of 52 weeks on on
the road so I was on stage a lot like a
lot you know and like I was saying at
the time I loved it you know I didn't
think about how often I was gone or who
I wasn't seeing like that that was my
only focus was to get out and do standup
what are I always ask people about like
their like worst bombing or like worst
gigs I mean what it what were some of
yours or like one that sticks out
there's two that stick out um um there
was
one you had a PTSD well one I talk about
on stage um and I didn't even like it
was so bad that I never even thought
about telling it as like a horrible
comedy story it just sort of came out
when I was I was on The Bob and Tom Show
one day and we were talking about hell
gigs and I started telling this story
and uh and then somebody was like you
need to talk about this on stage so when
I tell it on stage I open with saying
like it's great to be here and and I'm
and I mean that because this is a good
gig and I know a good gig because I've
done terrible gigs and uh when I had
first started doing standup a woman from
the Dayton Dragons Baseball team which
is the single a team for the Reds came
up to me after a show and had this idea
uh you know minor league baseball teams
are known for like all the silly stuff
that they do between Innings and she was
like I got this idea that
um that a comedian would dress up like
an Umpire and that the Umpire would come
into the dug out like the real one and
then you would put on the mask and go
out and then we'd make an announcement
that hey well we got a couple minutes
the umpire's also a comedian and then
you go out and you do jokes dressed like
the
Umpire and she was like we'll pay you
and and she's like it's a sold out crow
I mean I've been doing comedy six months
she's like 100 bucks come on out she's
like little I was like all right I'm 6
months in I'm getting paid standing up
in front of 12,000 people awesome so I
drive up to
Dayton um and right before I'm supposed
to go out I've got the whole gear on the
Umpire there's like a close play at the
plate and the Umpire makes like the
wrong
call and the star player jumps in his
face and starts jawing with him and he
throws him out of the game
and then the manager goes out to argue
and he gets thrown out of the game and
now everyone hates this guy that I'm
about to pretend to be and I'm just and
the the dude that was with me is like do
you want to do you like want to wait a
couple Innings I was like yeah you know
and so so then they're like it's such a
longer story than this but they end up
making us go to the away team's Dugout
because the Umpire said if we're still
going to do this comedy thing I don't
want to be in the home team dugout with
all these players and stuff who who hate
me right so now we move he comes over
and um and they had this guy who walked
around with the mascot between Innings
he was like this big he's a he's a
linebacker for the Jets who lived in
Dayton Ohio in the summer and he would
throw out t-shirts to the crowd like
everybody L this guy and he told me
before I go out he's like if anything
goes weird I'll come out and you know
smooth it over and I was like awesome so
sure enough they make the announcement I
put the mask on I start walking out I'm
getting booed as I'm just walking to
home plate like you suck you know and so
uh so I started doing my act and uh and
they're kind of listening like they've
stopped booing and so I'm just like I
don't know if I should just wrap this up
and I
say I go there I I'd been making fun of
the flea market and people who go to the
flea market and I said are there any
NASCAR fans here tonight and they're
like you know and I was like NASCAR is
huge at the flea market and then boo I
mean they start throwing pretzels and
hot dogs and stuff and I'm just like I
don't know what to do cuz like my time's
up and and then I see that guy he he
comes jogging out of the Dugout and I'm
like oh cool he's coming you know to
tell everybody it was just a big joke or
whatever and at full
speed Spears me just like just like
crushes me and I'm just like laying on
the ground like I don't know if I'm
concussed or if I've had like a spinal
injury or whatever but the place is
losing their mind like they are it is
the coolest thing they've ever seen and
so he I remember this he picks up the
microphone on the ground that I had
dropped and then he just grabs me with
his other arm and throws me over his
shoulder
and he was like guys I'll take out the
trash tonight and they're like yeah you
know and I just remember like like going
on the on his back off the field like
like I can't breathe or anything you
know and he gets me underground he's
like you all right and I was like I was
like yeah that was that was crazy and he
goes he goes were you crying out there
and I was like no I was like I was like
I couldn't I couldn't breathe I was like
I can't believe I did this for $35
$355 oh I said 100 I was getting greedy
yeah 35 bucks I had invited my parents
to come watch me they were in the stands
I was like Mom Dad come watch me do
stand up in front of all these people
big deal so that's the one that
immediately jumps out for like hell gigs
uh in a club the worst one was a uh an
urban KN oh an Apollo night in
Cincinnati that uh I was invited to
perform on uh that Chad Johnson Chad ooo
former Bengals player uh it was his
night and my buddy Gary Owen was like
come do sometime oh yeah he's from
Cincinnati yeah yeah yeah I was like I
was like I don't I don't know if that's
the right environment for so my
wife and uh he's like they'll love you
come on I'll give you a good
introduction and I'm like I just don't
know and so cuz I'd been to those shows
before and you know I know you talked to
earthquake like I had done a ton ton of
like hosting for earthquake and rsj and
some more and and those are fine but the
Apollo kns they just pick someone that
they've decided they're not going to
like no matter what oh I've done those
in Atlanta all time yeah and so I go up
and I don't even get like the mic out of
the mic sand and I'm just getting booed
and booted and I was just like this is
dumb why why am I doing this and so
finally I just go all right cool and I
just put the mic in mic stand and I'm
like this is the worst experience I
think I've ever had in a comedy club and
I walk off stage and Gary runs up and
just starts scolding the audience and
he's just like this guy is my friend you
didn't even let him get a joke out he's
been on Comedy Central and I'm just like
that's really cool of him to do that you
know and uh and he goes I'm going to
bring him back up here do not I'm off to
the stage no do not I'm bringing him
back up here and you guys are going to
be nice then you're going to laugh at
I'm like why is he doing he's like give
it up again for Josh Le and I'm like and
I walk back up there and they're quiet I
get the mic out of the mic
stand so the othero and they just stting
again I was like dear I just put the mic
back in and walked off stage and that
one still that one still sting a little
bit cuz I never even got a chance it
wasn't even like I I bombed hard like it
was like I didn't even get a chance
yeah yeah we all go through those gigs
you know as a comedian like there's
always those ups and downs like did did
you ever have any because you've been
you I've been doing it 13 years did you
ever have any moments of like you wanted
to like quit or you're like doubting the
whole decision to quit a corporate job
to do
this I don't think so and I I say that I
say that just because like my career has
been a lot of good fortune and luck but
also being prepared like all kind of
intertwined together you know what I
mean so when I in ' 03 I'd been doing
comedy full-time for a couple years and
um I made the finals of this Comedy
Central contest called The Laugh riots
and what they were doing is they would
have shows all over the
country and then one winner from each
show got picked to go to Los Angeles for
the finals and um there were some great
Comics that had made like Kyle Canan was
in the finals Chad Daniels I think um
Chris Fairbanks just some really solid
super funny dudes
Kaki um and so I go out to LA and I
decide I'm going to move to LA and try
to capitalize off of like whatever like
little bit of heat or you know what I
mean kind of comes from this and and
like I said at that point I'm only 2
years into fulltime so I haven't had
anything but just like living my dream
on the road and so I moved to LA and uh
I'm starting to get some like on into
some of the local clubs and then I
signed with a
manager um and I said whatever he tells
me to do I'm going to do like I'm not
going to I'm young I have no idea what
I'm doing or what it takes to make it
out here so whatever he says I'm going
to listen and so I signed with this guy
and and he says no more shows in LA and
I was like what and he goes until you've
either done a festival or been on TV I
don't want you doing any shows in La
he's like it's very important for people
to see you in the right light when they
make their first impression of you and
if you just do some show where you have
a bad set or it's a bad crowd then
that's their that's how they see you is
like somebody who's just not ready he's
like I want them to see you in the right
light first and I was like okay I'm not
going going to pretend to know better
and so um my roommate at the time got
engaged and then got married within 5
months of meeting the girl MH gets
engaged and married so now I'm living
with a married couple in La I'm not
doing any shows when I'm not on the road
because my manager told me not to and so
almost instantly I was like I think I'm
just going to move back to Cincinnati I
mean I was there for like seven months
wow yeah and and it was a tough pill to
swallow but a good friend of mine
finesse Mitchell had made Saturday Night
Live so he had moved from LA to New York
and I was going to New York all the time
to hang out with him and and and hang
out at SNL and I was like maybe that's a
better play for me but while I decide I
just I can't stay in La cuz I'm on the
road constantly just to afford living
here so I moved back home 7 months after
I after I had gone to LA and and uh and
so I moved home January of
04 and then uh July of 04 I got Montreal
and August of 04 I got premium blend on
Comedy Central so i' had been home five
months and I had done both of the things
he told me I had to do but I wasn't I
mean I had spent all my money moving
back home oh my God so I was like I'm
not going to go right back I'm just
going to stay here for maybe a year
decide what I want to do like all your
money like did you move back home or I
moved back to an apartment oh but on
your own still well see here's what
happened when I'm going out to LA at you
know 23 or whatever like I'm going to be
there for a long time so I'm not going
to take furniture I'm going to go buy it
new out there you know I'm going to uh
get get a whole new setup so I get out
to LA I buy all this brand new
furniture and then s months later I'm
like I will get pennies for this you
know and I don't have anything back home
so I spent like four grand to move this
brand new furniture back home like have
a truck like drive it back to Cincinnati
and then I just loaded up my car with
everything else and drove home and so uh
and so I'm in I'm in I'm I'm in
Cincinnati you know I do Montreal and I
do premium blend and then the next year'
05 I decide I'm going to submit for a
half hour and uh and I don't get it but
they invite me to perform at the South
Beach Comedy
Festival uh in July of ' 06 it was the
fir or I'm sorry January of ' 06 it was
the first time that Comedy Central was
going to try their own festival and uh I
knew there really wouldn't be any
industry there because it's Comedy
Central is the one putting it on but it
was like you know to get in better with
them and a free trip to Miami in January
when you live in Ohio I was like
absolutely and so I was put on an
outdoor show that was free which those
two things you know are typically
recipes for disaster for comedy nobody
paid to get in and Outdoors yeah the
baseball game prime example yes so uh
but the show is great it's uh Sebastian
Maniscalco is also on the show uh
relatively unknown Sebastian
Maniscalco uh Brett erns is on the show
Jessica
kerson uh a lot of super solid Comics my
God every comic you're naming is like
kill it I they're so great it's so cool
and uh and so the shows were really fun
the way that Comedy Central had it set
up at this outdoor venue was really cool
and then um I get off stage from one of
my shows and uh this girl goes you got
to come with me and I was like something
wrong and she's like no she's like Greg
Geraldo is at the the theater down the
street and he didn't bring an opener and
so we showed him the list of people on
this show and he knows you and he's like
have Josh come do it so I like we we
like Scurry down to this theater and uh
he's like thank you for doing it I'm
like dude of course I mean he's like one
of my gri in peace but one of just the
alltime oh for sure and uh and he's like
just can you just do like 20 I was like
of course so I go out and I do 20
minutes and then after the
show um we're walking to this red carpet
event that Brett erns and I are going to
be hosting for Comedy Central and the
girl gets a call and uh and she's like
she's like he
is he does oh he does and she's like
looking at me like okay I'll I'll let
him know and I was like what was that
all about and she said that the
president of Comedy Central was in the
audience to see Greg Geraldo and he
wanted to make sure that he met me after
the show at the part at the after party
wow and so I got to meet Doug Herzog and
then two weeks after that I got offered
my Comedy Central presents and so then
that comes out and um and then they have
this standup Showdown on comedy
Central's website and I ended up coming
in second behind Jeff Dunham who was
already doing Arenas so it felt like I
came in first and then that got me a
record deal with Comedy Central so my
first album was on Comedy Central
Records and I say that because it's it
always was just like a little bit every
year felt like just a little bit of
progression to something you know MH and
it it never there was never that long of
a gap where I
questioned like did I make the right
decision you know what I mean and so um
in that time I'd started the t-shirt
company with my buddy and that was kind
of giving me something to do during the
days and you know he was an art academy
graduate so he would do do the design
and then I'd go out on the road and I'd
wear our our funny t-shirts to radio
stations or I'd sell them at the shows
and that sort of how we started to build
that brand up and uh it was just it was
just kind of fun because it was like it
was it was just like spending money you
know at that time but even even you
having all this success and literally I
mean at that time in comedy like Comedy
Central special I mean that's it like
that's like you made it but even at that
time you're like but I need I need I
need some other income because I don't
know if this is like I feel like if I
was in that position I'd be like Oh I'm
the chosen one I've had all this fast
progression yeah I'm I'm Invincible but
like what was it in you that's like this
is all cool but I'm already thinking
long term that I don't want to be doing
this as heavily well it wasn't even that
it was that you know um so on a on a
sadder note in in 07 um um which was
like right after my special had come out
um my dad got sick and then he passed in
February of ' 08 and so I wasn't Mar I
was still single at the time but he and
I were so close that it gave me this
like this sort of like I don't know it
was kind of like sobering in a way that
like man I thought he was going to be
around for a long time and now he's not
and so if I do get married and have kids
like I can't just assume that I can be
on the road and you know I'll come back
and everything will be peachy like it it
really drove home the thing of like you
got to take advantage of like certain
moments in in their lives that you won't
get a second chance at you know what I
mean and so um and so
ironically to get when I got my Comedy
Central record deal it was right after
my my dad had passed away the week after
his funeral I headlined my home Club go
bananas and then a month later I got the
album deal and they said where would you
like to record it and I said I want to
record it at my home Club but I was just
there like a month ago and they're like
well do you think you could do like a
Friday Saturday and just let people know
that this is a a special recording and
that they would come back out again and
I I felt like I knew enough people that
I could let them know like hey this is
probably going to be stuff if you came
it's going to be a lot of the same stuff
but here's the situation and so in two
months after I just played there I did
it again and then we sold out all four
shows and the and that's how I got my
album recording well my now wife was in
the audience that night which I had not
met her but um she sent me a note uh
after after she had seen the show and
you know fast forward a couple months
after that we start dating
and then uh a year later we're engaged
you know a year later we're married a
year later we have our first kid and so
again it wasn't that much time where I
was sort of like all right well I don't
want to be on the road for first steps
and first words and you know what I mean
mhm and so the t-shirt company slowly
started to become more important as like
a supplement than just like something
I'd been doing for fun you know what I
mean yeah and so um so it was really
cool to kind of see the growth of that
but it was also very nice in that it
afforded me the chance to be home for
like what I think are like super
important moments as a parent and a and
a husband you know and so um you know
the plan was always well when he gets
you know a little bit older like starts
kindergarten or something where my wife
isn't responsible for keep keeping an
eye on him 24 hours a day if I'm not
around that'll make it easier to start
gradually going back on the road and
kind of turning the attention back to
picking up where I left off you know so
to speak with uh with standup and then
when he was five my daughter was born
and so that kind of like reset that
clock wow you know but again I've been
very lucky that during that time where
it's been very purposeful you know I
haven't generated as much material matal
as I'd like you know I was able to
record the dry bar thing when that
opportunity came along and um you know
the success of that was amazing you know
both for exposure to new fans but also
like you know some income during a
global pandemic that no one could see
coming yeah um but you know like Co was
like a real wakeup call I think for a
lot of comics of like if if we can't do
live
shows what else are we what else could
we do you know yep and I was lucky
because I I had something um you know I
didn't start a t-shirt company to help
me get through Co but it helps you know
and um I had also been approached by a
candy company based out of Cincinnati
that makes AirHeads and
Mentos um they they had decided they
wanted a comedian to run their social
media and knew that I was local and
asked if I wanted to um you know be
their voice online and so uh so I've
been doing that for 10 years 10 years
yeah oh wow and no one knows it's me
yeah so if you ever if you're ever
talking to Mentos orad you're talking to
me whoa and uh and so that's been great
supplement income but what that did is
it made me realize that we have
skills that if you just think think
outside of like writing a movie or or
acting you know but like where else
where else is it is it needed to have a
professional comedian writing you know
like social media for Brands is
something that they all struggle with
and whenever they hire an ad agency it
always comes across very sales pitchy
you know it's not engaging it's not
witty um and so I was like lucky that
another company saw all that in me and
so um yeah it's just been it's been
great you know I take Summers off I
don't work between from Comedy right you
don't do comedy during the summer from
miday to Mid August I do no no shows um
my wife has been uh stay-at-home for six
years so she hasn't had to work you know
and all that stuff is like super
important it's very important to me but
you know to the amount of stress that
she has to deal with like trying to
limit that so that she doesn't have any
animosity towards standup because of how
much more work it puts on her plate when
I'm gone you know like all that stuff
like adds up to reducing overall stress
in our house which makes it so much more
enjoyable and to not have that kind of
pressure that I mean that's this
literally where I'm at right now with
pre- pandemic I was on the road more
than ever I was starting to headline a
lot of Comedy zones like basically as a
comedian it's like oh I worked 10 years
to oh I'm a road comic now like full
like fulltime in all this and then
pandemic hits I'm unemployed overnight
and now roog gigs are starting to come
back and I'm like I don't really want to
be gone like that anymore so why I'm at
a point now of like well what else can I
do you know I'm kind of in like a
transitional period right now like what
are what are some other side hustles
You' seen comedians do or like or advice
you have for for me like I mean like
tell me what to do Josh how can I be how
can I make money from home well you know
I mean seriously it's uh it's cliche but
like if you can just find something that
you're good at and you enjoy doing that
doesn't feel like work MH like you'll
find that the business will come you
know as you hone your your skills in
that you know um I I wasn't a skilled
trade Tradesman for screen printing you
know but I found it fun and I could I
felt like I had a knack for coming up
with Concepts that translated well to
t-shirts right and so um I think this
podcast is like a great place for you to
be because I mean you do such a great
job with it and you create awesome
content with it you know that um I think
I think you're going to figure out a way
to unlock this you know
because comparative to what a lot of
other people are doing like you're just
doing such a better job at
it and that's not that's not really a
slight to them as much as it is to like
you just you just see it and you get
your vision you get your aesthetic for
it you know and uh and I would I would
stay on this path and then I mean I've
heard of comics doing all kinds of stuff
but it's more it's more of like making
ends meet than it is you know um like I
see a future in this and it's like a
business that I could scale right do you
know what I mean and I think that's the
difference is
like what what are you are you just
trying to supplement your income with
whatever so that you don't have to be
gone all the time or you trying to find
something else that can sort of grow in
its own time while you do standup and
hopes that when you're ready to stop
that this can take over and and you can
live comfortably off I'm looking for you
cuzz that's what happened with the
t-shirt company like I said I didn't
need it to be successful in 2005 I
needed it to be successful by
2015 do you know what I mean yeah um and
so you know F I don't know I mean I wish
it was there was easy advice but it
really is just find something that you
like doing that that you you don't have
to put the pressure on yourself for it
to be successful right now it can grow
while you
have this other thing and then as it
grows you know who knows what'll happen
yeah I enjoy I enjoy doing this podcast
and I've been doing it seven years so I
am at a a point now of like all right
we've been doing it we've interviewed a
lot of super like cool people and now
it's like all right how can I turn this
into a business basically so that's
where I'm at after doing this for so
long as well I mean we can I mean I
don't want to give all my
secrets I'll get I'll tell you after
we're done you're when I think you
should the next episode not more like
gold chains like you know Joshua was
right from your from your giant home
studio yeah yeah yeah uh no it's uh I
don't know there's no easy thing but
right it Whatever It Is find it you know
have an idea work it out Workshop it out
see if there's a future in it and if
there's not move on to something else
you know yeah but um but your peace of
mind and your stress level and the
things that you feel like you have to do
to maintain the things that are
important to you besides comedy that's
worth the time and effort to figuring
out what it is do you know what I mean
for sure yeah um because as fun as this
business is you know it you get paid you
don't get I always say a lot of comics
say you don't get paid to perform you
get paid for all the stuff that you have
to do to perform you get paid to be away
from your family and live out of a
suitcase and stay in hotels and have
canceled flights or rent cars you know
what I mean like that's what you're
being paid to do getting on stage is is
the easy part so you know um I wish
there was a simple answer but uh you'll
you'll figure it out knowing that there
should be something is the biggest step
like not putting all of your eggs in the
basket and just assuming that I can do
this forever and it'll always be there
that's the you have the right mindset
now of knowing that there's something
else that you could be doing and finding
that out will be the fun part but you're
on the right path already dude oh wow
well well thank you for saying that I
like I like the fortune cook I
like I appreciate the optimism there
because it really was cool in
researching you and us cuz I mean I've I
I I I would come and watch you at like
the old punchline like I so I've been
aware of you for a while but I didn't
realize your story of like and you
coming up around all these other like
super successful comedians as well like
there's you could see certain
trajectories in your career that you
could go but you're like but I want to
do this for me and like my family and
like just find a different way two
things that I think are very important
on that is one you have to you have to
genuinely
be
um happy for other people's success
right like the guys that I would
consider like my closest friend my peers
when I was like kind of coming up
through like the feature ranks you know
Chad Daniels Roy Wood Jr Dan cumins
Jamie lisso Pete Lee you know like guys
that are doing like real cool stuff
right now you know whether it's just in
standup or on TV or movies like those
were my best friends and
I was so lucky to figure out a way to
like be happy for them and not be
jealous of them because we were on very
similar paths at the same time you know
what I mean yeah it's super easy to I
think get jealous of people you don't
know personally and you don't know their
backstory but when you know that you've
come from the same spots as some of the
other people in the same clubs at the
same
time um you know like I I love those
guys still today and I'm so happy for
all of them um so finding finding a way
to be at peace with your success and not
compare it to other people whether
they're you know somebody that you
consider a peer or not is huge but also
your definition of success is huge and I
say I say this whenever I get the chance
Dave
Chappelle said something on inside the
actor Studio that literally changed my
life life it CH the second I heard it it
changed my life because I was living in
Ohio I was debating on whether or not I
needed to go back to LA or move to New
York if I really wanted to take it to
the next step and it wasn't out of a
need it was just out of like me getting
in my own head about what do we
typically consider the definition of
successes as a comedian and from the
first time you start it's always do you
have your own show do you are you a
movie star Are you a writer you know
like it it's it was always like the
Pinnacle of the industry was what you
considered success you know and Dave W
when he was on inside the actor Studio
they he asked him you know what did your
parents think when you told them you
wanted to become a comedian and uh and
he said they thought it was a phase you
know they thought that it was it was
something temporary and and one of his
parents said well will you stop doing it
if you're not successful
and his response to them was well that
depends on what your definition of a
success is and he says if a teacher
makes $40,000 a year and I can make
$40,000 a year doing standup I'd rather
be a comedian than a
teacher and so when I heard that I was
like you know what that's so true like
if I can live in pretty much anonymity
in Cincinnati Ohio and pay my bills I
could pay them just doing standup if I
wanted you know you know that's success
like that's a that's a success in the
entertainment industry like just cuz I'm
not famous or selling out Arenas but I
can make a as good of a living as my
neighbor who's a executive for Proctor
and Gamble or this guy across the street
who's a a lawyer you know like if I can
make as much money at them doing this
and nobody knows who I am that's still
success you know and so if I just learn
to be happy that I can make a living
doing what I love then I don't have to
worry about the things that I didn't get
or all the stuff that I haven't done you
know what I mean yeah yeah and so like I
I would sell any comic who's not you
know sort of zeroed in on the you know
selling out Arenas or having a Netflix
special like if you if you can make a
living doing what you love like that's
that's success like that's something 90%
of the population can't say right about
whatever it is they do you know um Jimmy
Paro is like one of my all-time favorite
comics and he shared a quote on his
podcast a long time ago that I always
think about too and he said you know
something along the lines of and it may
not have been his quote but that's who I
heard say it and he was saying you know
if you if you always think of success as
a ladder you know you're always like
trying to climb and like see who's in
front of you and very rarely do you take
time to like look down and see how far
you've come you know and so you know I
try to remind myself of that sometimes
where it's like think about anybody
that's ever come up to you after a show
and said I thought about giving this a
try you know my friend say I'm funny you
know I can I can get up there like of
all those people like how many people
actually do one open mic night and then
of those people like how many do a
second or a third and then of all the
people who like love doing Open Mic
nights how many get to get paid as an MC
one time and how many get to be regulars
and then how many of those get to be
features and how many of those get to be
Headliners and you start with that and
then you get down to this and you
realize that just being a headliner at
the Atlanta punchline is a spot reserved
for at the most 52 people in one year
and you get to do it every year like
it's how do you not be grateful for just
getting that far yeah you know what I
mean wow yeah that's perspective there I
think you it's more important to figure
out a way to be happy with what you have
than constantly worrying about what
other people have or the things that you
don't have yeah do you find as soon as
you like cuz like me right now I'm like
trying to force something to happen but
if you found like when you just like let
go that that's when like oh that's where
the Breakthrough is when you stop trying
to like suffocate it yeah I think so
yeah yeah I I've only gotten one
commercial ever and it was the one
audition that I did not care about yeah
I always think about that I just went in
with this like whatever I never get
these you know and I got it you know uh
the South Beach Comedy Festival I took
it because it was like it's a free trip
to Miami well president of Comedy
Central was in the audience and it got
me a half hour special you know dry
bar never heard of it but the tapes look
good so I'm going to do it to get a good
tape out of it and then more exposure
than anything I've ever done in my life
you know what I mean like you just don't
know but I think it goes back and I I
tried to get this mentality when Last
Comic Standing was really big cuz I
would notice that the people who did
really well on Last Comic Standing they
that were like seasoned Comedians and
had like a lot of experience in the
clubs we're able and I see it on
America's Got Talent now too when that
opportunity for that like next level
success is presented to
you if you're prepared to accept it then
that's what all the hard work was for
you know so that's kind of like what I
try to tell myself is like if it comes
great I know that I'm ready for it I've
stayed sharp I feel like as a comic I've
never been sharper on stage right now uh
you know my my daughter is now seven so
I've again started to turn back to like
generating new material and flushing out
these premises I've literally just been
keeping in a book for like the last
feels like 10 years yeah um because
they're good you know they're they're
they're into their own things now and
they love me and I love them and they
know that I'm around and that I'm not
going to be on the road all the time but
uh you know my wife doesn't have to be
watching them all the time if I'm not
around so it's easier on her so now I've
kind of started to shift my focus back
and I've been flushing out new material
and I'm probably I don't know 85% to
like a an hour of material that has not
been ever recorded and so that's like
exciting for me at you know 46 to like
still have that feeling you know 25
years into the business of still being
like
this excites me I got new stuff I got
people that want to hear it when I put
it out like that's that's the goal right
you yeah was there anything that you
learned as we like maybe like as an
encapsulating piece of advice for Comics
out there or is like there anything you
learn from working with all these
amazing people that maybe you could
apply to like younger
Comics I tried to
learn whatever I could like I said I was
a sponge so I mean it everything from
the performance side like what to do
with the microphone like a mic stand or
you know how close to hold the
microphone when to scream when to
whisper how to deal with the check drop
how to deal with the Heckler like you
can just learn I feel like as much by
watching professionals as you can by
actually being up there I think they're
both important um so I would say be be a
sponge go to the club even when when
you're not on the show to just like
network but also just like see see if
you can learn something by watching and
then off
stage um Larry the Cable Guy taught me a
very valuable lesson about like
appreciating fans you know we did a show
Once in West Virginia
where um I think there's probably like
3,000 people at the show and our show
was like an hour and a half but we were
in the lobby for three 3 hours
afterwards because he let everyone that
wanted to come through the line and meet
him he stayed there until the last
person left and so I was just like that
I just said I was like man that was
really impressive and he said that guy
that just waited 3
hours the fact that I was still standing
here like he'll remember that that guy
will be a fan
forever and he was just like if you just
appreciate
the people that pay money and come out
like those are the ones that are going
to go out and tell other people that
they should check you
out and so I try to keep that I mean I'm
not waiting three hours after a show
it's usually it usually can meet
everybody that wants to say hi in about
eight minutes big
self
everybody um but I just try to remember
that because uh you know it's still I'm
still kind of getting used to it I know
you've had some some bigname guys on
this show but it's new to new to me even
this late into my career that people
show up because you were there you know
it it's it's it's a such a great feeling
I mean when you become a headliner a lot
of times the shows that you're doing
from the traditional route not because
you developed a huge following online
but just working your way up right um
people are at the show because they
wanted to go to the comedy club that
night you know whoever was there was
there but they wanted to see a comedy
show and when that slowly starts to
shift to people that are there because
you're there you know and then it gets
even crazier to
like I was in Phoenix back in March and
uh this couple was like we we couldn't
wait to see your show and I was like oh
cool I was like are are you guys from
around here like well we're from Utah
and I was like oh nice and I go but you
live here now and they're like no we
drove here from Utah for tonight and I'm
just like I like I can't even wrap my
head around it you know
that that Phoenix was the closest I was
going to be to Utah so they're like
let's drive like I can't there are not
words for how that makes you feel as a
comedian to know that you've left an
impression on a stranger to a degree
that they would go through all of that
just to watch you on stage for an hour
wow and so those little moments are what
keep me going to want to to try to give
the best show I can when I am performing
but also
to not give up you know what I mean like
know that how cool would it be if there
was a room full of people that said that
instead of just one table you know so
that's kind of my
my goal in moving forward and trying to
progress my career versus just like
treading water so you almost have the
t-shirt business running now it's like a
30 person operation now I think so it's
like now you kind of got that plate
spinning and now that your family is a
little more like they're a little more
grown up doing their own things now
you're like okay back to back to what it
come in Full Circle here oh that's
exciting man it is it's very exciting
for me I'm really excited about this new
special getting it recorded and putting
it out there because just you know like
the dry bar
stuff as awesome as it was it was a lot
of old material there was only a couple
of bits that didn't exist on a previous
album or my Comedy Central special and
so now that I know that there's like an
audience out there that's kind of into
what I do like it's really exciting for
me to go here's something I know you've
never heard before cuz I haven't had
that feeling in a long time oh that's ex
well I'm excited to do this interview at
that moment in your career as well it's
a very good time let's do it where where
could people um where would you like
people to keep up with you and come see
you live how can they keep up with all
your good stuff just at Josh sne on
whatever social media I'm I'm I'm on all
of them and I pretty much post the same
stuff on all of them just try to cover
my bases so you know I try to share and
create little funny online things you
know I'm not a big sharer of standup
Clips um I know that's all the rage and
maybe that's that's what is holding me
back is not sharing more of my ACT but
I'm just I don't I don't want to go down
the crowd work whole as as lucrative as
I know as it is there's guys that are
and girls that are so much better at it
than me it's not part of what people
would actually see at my
show and um so that's why I'm not really
doing that and then as far as my
material goes most of what I would put
out there now is stuff that's already
out there on Dry Bar Comedy Central or
something all the stuff that isn't is
stuff that I'm saving for this next hour
so once that gets done I'm sure it'll
get chopped up into little Clips as well
but that's why I'm not sharing any of
those now so the stuff I put out now is
more just like memes and you know like
silly little things that I do or stuff
that my kids say so if you're into that
kind of thing give me a follow or come
see me in your town when I'm there and
you can hear the new material yeah and
if people enjoyed this you know please
reach out to joshu on social media and
let them know and if you're not already
subscribe to our YouTube channel where
you can get access to this plus over 400
other interviews we've done with
comedians all about comedy and send Joel
money like pay this man for this amazing
content because he deserves it and it's
worth it and if you want to see it
continue then you got to support it
patreon.com brep
pod we'll see you there Josh sne thanks
for being on hot breath dude thank you
brother I appreciate it awesome woo that
was good that was great what about that
yeah I do H breath